some people can't shake the feeling that
the phones may be picking up their
conversations even when they're not
making a call recent headlines highlight
how some consumers believe they could be
getting ads just by chatting about
products in normal conversation Tony
Duke opal did some research of his own
Tony good morning good morning I was one
of those consumers if you're getting
online ads for things you never searched
for online you may think a company is
listening in and that is possible
experts say but companies know so much
about you already they probably don't
need to eavesdrop so you've had this
feeling that your phone is listening to
oh definitely samne when is sure she
gets ads from Facebook and Google for
things she only mentions out loud I
didn't write that in my email I didn't
check it out online yet it's just
popping up that's kind of weird weird
enough to convince her the companies are
eavesdropping through her phone's
microphone but are they I think that's
very very unlikely Sandeep Eric Ellis is
a former Facebook operations manager he
says constant streams of audio from so
many phones would be too expensive to
gather and analyze and all the data
would drive up people's phone bills
besides he says companies don't have to
listen to know what's on your mind they
know a tremendous amount about you and
that that enables them to make guesses
about what to advertise to you that can
be uncannily accurate that's because
they already mine a cross-section of
personal data including almost
everything we post share and search for
online for the last few years it's
gotten incredibly more invasive and I
think that it continues in that
direction unless we stop it this is a
home page so Gabriel Weinberg has been
trying to do just that through his
company DuckDuckGo he opened my Google
account to demonstrate just how much
information has been collected about me
today this is just yesterday a hundred
and fifty nine different items that
they've tracked you across had search
maps YouTube books google says it has
access to 70% of credit and debit card
transactions in the United States
with Facebook and others it also
monitors much of what we're doing across
the web using hidden tracking
technologies the companies can see many
of the pages you and people connected to
you are visiting allowing them to better
tailor their ads according to the author
of one study google has trackers on 76%
of websites while Facebook watches us on
23% of sites would you say that the
advertising model for the Internet is
based on a breach of privacy I think it
has passed that level for Facebook and
Google how so and that people don't
realize that they can be targeted to the
degree that they are but people like
Bill buddington can watch the Watchers
there's all this data that it's sending
out we asked the security researcher
from the Electronic Frontier Foundation
to help us with a test maybe you'll find
a deal out there for a Cuisinart coffee
maker yeah
we discussed several household products
while he monitored activity on a nearby
cell phone watching for any secret audio
transmissions so from what you're able
to see today bottom line has that phone
been listening to our conversation we
haven't seen any audio recordings being
sent and we never saw ads for the
products we discussed either yet even if
companies are listening to people as Sam
no when suspects she tells us she's not
overly concerned that's helpful
a few actually she sees an upside to
advertisers knowing her so well it is
creepy for sure it is very creepy but
I'm not completely like oh my god this
is terrible
Google and Facebook have both denied
using cell phone microphones to collect
information for ads in a statement
Google wrote we do not use ambient sound
from any device to target ads and while
facebook did not respond to our request
for comment it previously said we show
ads based on people's interest and other
profile information not what you're
talking about
out loud but the fact remains they know
so much about us already they don't need
to listen in so it's just a coincidence
a ssin then all of a sudden it appears
on the phone do you believe that now
after doing the piece I do believe that
because as one of the experts pointed
out to me our phones are gathering so
much about us that we volunteered that
it's almost like in those old cop
detective movies where there's two guys
in a car down the street watching you at
all times that's happening through our
phones every day what about through our
emails same thing you know you can
search those sift those everything we
post everything we share everything we
voluntarily disclose if you think this
is happening and you see the ad it
confirms your previous bias it's true
well I'm with I'm with a woman with the
baby said it's creepy but it's not so
unsettling working for her yeah yeah
thank you Tony
yeah thank you